ah today is a beautiful day because
today we're looking at
tlc 90 day fiance i don't know how they
do it but they always find the most
insane couples of all time and i love it
i'm not afraid
to say it i love it i i love it
and today we're looking at chantel
and pedro does that not look like me a
little bit what the [ __ ]
the problem with these is that they're
scattered all right here we go pedro age
chantal 20s wait a minute i know this oh
god i've seen
how they met yeah yeah yeah they learn
they learn spanish together
over the app like those apps where you
teach each other the language
they met and they fall in love chantal
went to dominican republic
and then they oh why do i know this
this is so sad this is what i've been
filling my brain with
anyway let's watch i actually have no
idea what happened after that so this
should be interesting what
what has happened between pedro and
chadel
that's how you say their names in
dominican republican no whatever
everything's right okay that's smooth
see those uh spanish-speaking countries
they are smooth
don't worry baby everything is okay okay
don't worry baby everything is gonna be
okay doesn't even speak the language but
he knows how to sweesel in there
i'm really confused about my marriage
right now uh-huh
why confronted pedro about what he said
last night at the winery
and how he's planning to go back to the
dr he's going back to the dr
oh the dominican republic i thought she
meant doctor
that you had serious plans to go back to
your country and we haven't even spoke
about this
yeah i think what's fun about these
is figuring out who's the villain right
there's always
either it's the foreigner or it's the
local one
i'm saying localized america is local to
me but the
medicare republic is probably closer but
that's the fun is it pedro
yeah don't worry baby everything is
gonna be okay i'm not going to leave in
there
she gone there for a couple of a couple
of weeks maybe
one two weeks he doesn't want to go back
to dr maybe he should eat an apple
because it keeps the dr away
that's fine i don't need that to some
degree
but i still feel like i don't know what
pedro's
true intentions are for our future i
think
pedro wanted a little better what's
covering half your body jesus christ
and he was done anyone leaving you here
you gotta stay
good morning pedro chantel ago money
whoa what the hell how did you sleep did
you sleep well last night uh
the way he speaks is beautiful and he
reminds me when i try to talk to
marcia's parents
hey ciao
pedro we definitely want to talk to you
about what was said yesterday
ah god i know what it is oh my god
he sounds like the guy from the room
thomas please
i don't want to talk last night you know
it's america when they have
juices this in size pedro mentioned that
he would be
going back to the island so that's the
mom
and that he would not be taking chantel
with him
desperate to find out what actually is
going on with people what happened
in the dr we could find something
extremely sinister
we were definitely on the impression
that you were going to go to school
once chantelle finishes school he was
gonna go back to school
oh i remember now i remember now
okay i can get backstory this is the
problem because on the internet they
don't upload the whole
context but i remember so i can explain
it to you don't worry
she lied right she said he was just
gonna come over
to stay for a little while like two
weeks but she didn't mention that they
already got married
ah and also this guy's demeanor legend
i would love to be this guy we were
definitely on the impression that you
were
hey pedro we were definitely under the
impression that uh
you were gonna get the [ __ ] out of here
after you were done with your [ __ ] my
dude
oh i can't wait to get old and just be
an [ __ ]
[Music]
i must be crazy because you said you
were leaving
but i can still see you in front of me
the [ __ ] you're doing here so
we were really surprised so we're like
really you must understand
he's talking like a mafia boss it's so
passive aggressive i love it
you must understand how confusing this
must be to me
you are still around you understand my
dilemma hey
[Music]
i understand how confused i must be
right now why is it so fun to talk like
that
and especially it's got their apple
juice and we
found it chantelle you didn't seem to
know anything okay
i i know leaving shantae hilo you know
you're going to me gotta publish for
a couple of weeks one week three days
four days for once i am so glad they
added the subtitles what the
that's not what you said last night you
mentioned some months no
no no no no
no no no that's not that you need a
drone too you take it the other way
the only person that was drunk at the
winery
was you
the drone you know i are you drunk right
now or
what's happening oh god i spin the beans
and the winery i wish not telling the
central family
but i going i'm going back to vr well
whatever business it
is i hope that it is not a
this feels like watching like a very
poorly acted soap opera and i
love it i absolutely love it
land organized marriage ring
type of business
on this well this is organized marriage
i saw your mother's website
oh advertising for dominican
women that wanted to get married
american ah oh look at [ __ ] that's nice
what i know that pedro's her mother's
website is
a lawyer but i believe
lydia is a business to find
stupid americans
did she just call her daughter a stupid
you dumb on live television well god
bless
parents to match with
a person on the island to harvest the
american dollar
and i have a feeling shentel was
introduced to pedro
for that same reason but they met over
the app
mom they met over the app this doesn't
add up
chantel mom talks so slow like damn i
feel like fishing sets enough for her
pedro's actions when his family comes
around all right
pedo fights with chantel's brother fight
yes i'd like to get to the bottom of
this
i would like to know what nicole's
motives are
oh my god she's right now i can't get
past it she speaks so freaking slow
hey yeah yeah yeah
[Applause]
whoa he slept the lap that's an ikea
life don't ever slept by klm
oh [ __ ] oh oh oh
[Applause]
see i knew that was going to get out of
control because he slapped that keel
lamp but
man if anyone ever ever stops i can't
laugh
in front of me god damn
family family dinners right they're
crazy sheesh
oh the producer has to come to bed
healthy relationship am i right go get
married abroad with someone you don't
know why not
yeah what could go wrong i did that [ __ ]
never mind uh
[ __ ]
all right here we come apology
that's a that's a good apology all right
yo whatever it says
i'm sorry okay you want an apology
i'm [ __ ] sorry okay oh thank you so
much thank you for the apology
yes
[Music]
oh is it are they here for the wedding
and they're already fighting so much
she could have a better guy than pedro
all right okay i guess pedro is the
villain
pedro has an extremely strong bond with
his mother
he's a mama's boy but i think another
good reason to not marry someone
because you marry someone that's a
moment boy you're not just marrying one
person
and we've seen that over and over on
this show that's a package
deal right there he shares a little too
much with his family and he should keep
our private business
private
so
[Music]
is
wow speaking really fast i don't really
understand
it's almost like she doesn't even care i
understood all of that
i mean there were subtitles but still
come on stupid americano
what what is she saying i don't
understand
wow i cannot deal with pedro's mom's
negativity right now
yeah what the hell i basically found out
that our whole marriage
is a scam why i knew it i saw it
i knew it ever since i drank that apple
juice
plot to use another person
it's almost borderline body trafficking
yes is it is it yeah
pedro has crossed the
line i think as a parent pedro
has gone one step
two chances mom was made for reality tv
you're right
holy [ __ ] step in to try to talk to
pedro to try to handle the situation we
should just go over there we need to
know that
you should talk to pedro don't go to my
house i am going to do something
stay away from my house oh [ __ ] they're
going to go to their house
they're going to go to pedro i shouldn't
have told you anything this is
my relationship yeah right i mean why is
their family so involved that's just a
recipe for disaster because everyone's
gonna have a different opinion
and at the end of the day you need to
make your own it's your relationship
not your family's relationship but it
seems like on both sides it's so deeply
connected
there was a big fight if my family goes
to see pedro right now
it's only going to make things a million
times yep
yes
she did not just do that i was not ready
for that motherfucker's a taser
she's gonna taste her husband oh
[ __ ] oh yeah let's go let's go champ
no don't go mom don't chase him don't do
it
oh my god holy [ __ ] i was not expecting
that
i am going to meeting with immigration
lawyer all right how are you doing
yeah good my mom and my sister
to living in the united states for the
state over here with me
i don't think that that's not how it
works yeah it's not everywhere that's
not going to work dude i live here i'm
gonna leave over here
okay you need to be a u.s citizen before
you can sponsor them
oh okay okay so there's a chance all
right they don't get citizenship
as soon as you get married right you
just get a visa to stay
and then after a couple of years right
you can apply for citizenship i think
that's how it works he's got
two years before he's a citizen uh i was
right mother's process will probably
take about a year and a half
but there is an exception if you're
married to a u.s citizen
then you are eligible right away in
order to
fall under that exception you have to
show that you're still married that
you're living together
you're providing additional evidence of
the relationship
and then you could have an interview
together
with you and your wife
yeah what's wrong with that a little bit
scared see somebody coming for the
interview
and then my wife you want to go with me
well why wouldn't she
[Laughter]
but the requirement is that she would
need to attend yeah that's
that's some pretty basic [ __ ] there
pedro do you feel like that my mother my
sister
never treat chantel well
and then maybe so maybe you should stand
up for your wife
say this is the woman i married and i
love her so you have to respect her if
you respect me
well now i know the real reason he got
married oh
you know something i want to be my
father
enjoy my brother but it's not going to
be like this
because you hit ikea lamp i can't
forgive
this he is not my family pedro
doesn't have a father in his life and he
doesn't have a brother
i would like to let him know that hey
this is a good family setting
that he needs to be a part of oh that's
nice
thomas i don't think the guy's trip is
gonna help you out
you have a young man who is using your
daughter
just straight up using her oh [ __ ]
people that lie
consistently are liars
and they cannot be trusted they can be
trusted to lie
damn that all right
here we go peter and gentle mommy pedo
enchanters families face off
the final battle avengers end game it
all
comes down to this
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i have no
idea what these people are saying but
i noticed that he's gonna have to fight
oh my god what a mess dad can't tell
i'm leaving trying to save that marriage
yeah i gotta see the taser scene
okay here we go taste him
out he knows she's got the taser
i don't want to tell you oh she's got
murdering rights
[Music]
we just want to know what happened in
the dominican republic
and the respect for our daughter
chantelle told us what happened oh she
she's got the
what on the island yeah what is that
what is that
oh they're crazy it's a flashlight a
tactical one
a tactical flashlight stuff that's a
weird way to
a gun it's a tactical through error
shooting it's a tactical bullet launcher
yeah bruh four years and the family's
still acting like this what the [ __ ]
god that's got to be exhausting wait
where are they calling her black
karen jesus first time i see a black
hair
oh my god what a toxic relationship how
do they deal with it
geez maybe marrying someone abroad isn't
a good idea after all guys
jesus christ well well well
that's another tlc apparently pedro
and chantal is still together so maybe
maybe all ends well ends well or
whatever the saying is
i don't know and i don't care this has
been pewdiepie thank you for watching
subscribing checking out the merch and i
see you guys next time party bro
hail ah children of
nine parts it's time to raise what was
once forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean